这个必须的安排
怎么提升我们的表达能力
怎么提升我们的协作能力
怎么提升我们的影响力
我和大家分享一个比较简单
而且非常有效的方法
我这个战号大部分视频都是这么做的
差不多五到十分钟一条视频
首先给大家分享一个支持
这个咱要搞清楚
就是我们好多人会说
其实我知道我动作得也好多东西
我说不出来
我知道很多东西
我用不出来
为什么
我们先接定就知道这个事
其实我们很多时候有认识一个东西
我们能看明白
我也能记住我们把这个就叫做知识
举不例子
宣草
这个草
图片有你认识
你也知道他是宣草
拿过来
就是宣草
你知道
但是你知道宣草的功效吗
你知道在什么情况下是使用这个宣草吗
你可能不知道
所以考试的时候
他一个图片
请问这是什么草
你答对了宣草
的分数
生活中你要是广州到这些知识
其实没什么用处
各位那里面把我的意思吗
一个最简单的有用的知识
就是你为什么用处来
你为什么说不出来
最简单结构
应该是这样的
就知识是对遗忘经验的总结
对吧
有用的知识通常是这样的
最简单的结构
在什么情况下
遇到了什么样的问题
当时的场景是什么样子的
然后我们用了一个什么样的方法
取得了一个什么样的结构
为什么会这样
抽象出来
形成一个知识
对吧
然后还有宪国案例
这是一个最简单的
就用的知识这一些相关信息
如果你没有这些信息
其实你是很难
把它说出来的
表辣出来的
对吧
九立的宣操
你拍照视频
给人说什么
说是宣操
雷斯营斯宣操
对吧
抽象到杂子你
你想想是不是这样子的
所以你一定要掌握一些
这一些最继续的知识
你才能表达
事实上一旦你掌握了这些信息
那表达就是太容易的事了
稍微调整一些结构就可以的
所以为什么平时我拍视频
基本上就一遍过
就是有这个很简单的结构
我先跟大家分享这个结构
一上来
你不能想说什么就说什么
为什么呢
因为每个人一刷视频
看个文章
对吧
到处都是知识
人平时这么看你的
所以你的东西要不然有趣
要不然好玩
要不然搞笑的
要不然
对我有用
所以用刚才那个结构
一上来你就问
你是不是有这样的问题
你是不是这个工作时间长了以后
请追痛呢
对不对
你是不是经常失明啊
对吧
你是不是有很多知识说不出来啊
用不出来啊
对吧
先把问题拿出来
然后问题后面请跟着结构翻
我个人把他细成为什么
你我并吗
我有要这是一种方法
那另外一种方法的话
就直接把高光时刻两出来
我的这个百万上号是怎么做的
教你三种方法
我的第一统金是怎么做的
你这是我真实的方法
你看知识什么
在什么情况下
遇到什么样的问题怎么结构
就我有通点
我通过你可以帮我结构
人们愿意看和有关
还有一种方式的话
我想达到
我想成为更好的自己
我想怎么怎么样
这个方法是什么
这是知识什么
什么情况下遇到什么样的问题
然后怎么做
可以达到什么
然后跟大家讲背后的一些
原理
这样的时候的话
尽量简单
用最简单的
就说人话
就不要用人家原来的话
为什么
如果你无法用原话用简单的话
用你自己的话
人们都能听懂的话说清楚
说明你根本就不懂
所以有些是我拍的视频
一个目的一个什么
其实是简单的这个东西
我到底是不是真的知道了
然后就是全部
还有的话
就是要有办理
尽量有案例
为什么
因为知识很难理解
但是案例也一看
通常就更容易理解
就容易看明白
这些圈划了
然后假装一些
开始有些设计
就有一些创新
人们就这喜欢一些
好的设计
然后美的东西
有设计感的东西
然后有创意的东西
你看我们这条视频
就会加一干了
我们哪里在哪呢
我们整个视频
其实就是我们今天讲的这个知识的
案例
你干什么一下
是不是很有设计感
随体不随体